I do think the Labour Party's position
on bricks is just not sure what it is
well how I see is is that they they
they're constantly criticizing the
government who deserve a lot of
criticism for their strategy but
actually the boat gonna wind up in the
same place is that we're out whatever
the cost and whatever the chaos I think
the the parliamentary Labour Party is
actually strongly united considering
that I think a lot of them are very very
unhappy with the with the direction on
brakes in particular would you vote for
Corbin
I've only Lane last time not vote Labour
next time although the brexit thing is
testing me right to the limit I'll be
honest because something you'd vote Tory
no no way no I want to see what happens
I I'm in a position now where whether
it's stuff for doing the new European
stuff I'm doing in the breaks a campaign
and what-have-you
I just think if you believe as I do that
the country has made a terrible choice
that the government is handling it
really really badly that breaks is gonna
cost you when you're living standards is
gonna cost us in our standing in the
world the chaos of watching this lot
trying to agree if I hear one more day
your your profession saying and the
cabinet is meeting to deed today to
agree it's Brexton strategy we've been
hearing that since 24th of June 2016 and
they still haven't got a bracing
strategy they still haven't gotten
agreed strategy so I actually think the
whole thing is a disaster yeah but
you're out of step with the rest of the
public on 52% of the population who
voted I get it said that we've had
enough of Europe fair enough
they did and you have to accept that you
have to understand why my point is I
think that as we now see how much is
costing the chaos the fact that this
money for the health service is never
gonna come the health services in crisis
in part because the government they
wrote it on the siren bus so I'm going
to get 315 you can quit in a week back
apparently yeah exactly
but it's not true it was a lie then and
it's a lie now so as people see there
and as they see the chaos of the
negotiations I think there comes a point
where the public thing hold on a minute
do we have to do this a nice that you
say I'm out of step I'm not persuaded by
that at all I actually do think if
you've fast forward a bit and sure when
she comes back with the deal
I hope Parliament votes against it I
hope that because the truth is there is
no deal available than that is better
than what we've got so you think a
second referendum on the deal I think a
first fresh referendum on what the final
outcome of these negotiations is with
the option of staying in what should
your own boss be doing as far as that's
concerned because he still has a strong
voice well I think Tony is is engaged in
this debate his right to be every time
he puts his head above the parapet
people want to shout at him and say who
was going to do with you and you caused
this with immigration anyway and blah
blah blah Iraq you know it's fine let
them do it but I actually think that
this is a point where everybody who
believes in what I believe in and the
other side to be fair if you believe in
this side fair enough
but I think if you believe something
very very strong you've got to argue for
it and so when I get so many people say
to you why can't you just get behind
brakes it and try and make it work I
don't believe in it and I look at the
way they're handling in it they're
handling it they don't believe in it
they know the reason to resume I think
looks haunted she knows this is a
disaster she knows deep down this is
going to damage the country she's
leading I understand why she feels she
has to do it because of the referendum
because the position I think she does
have a choice because I'm afraid that
now this is being driven this is now
being driven by a very very small number
of very right-wing MPs the fact that
Faraj and resmoke are effectively
driving now the strategies the
government she's got to stand up to them
she's actually going to say no my job is
to do the right thing for the country
not just to appease you lot but as you
know the way that the Conservative Party
is elected should be at an aria in no
time let's see let's see
people actually respond to leadership
people respond to leadership at the
moment we're getting no leadership on it
do you think strong leadership is
cyclical and we had someone like Tony
Blair who you know whatever your view he
did you unite the country there was that
landslide in 97 that we all know about
hundred and sixty-eight majority I think
it was wasn't it
and then we see someone like Mike romp
in in France and a lot of people are
rallying behind him because they like a
young fresh dominating politician we
we don't seem to have any at the moment
or do we is there a new crop coming
through that you can identify I don't
know because I think the good people I
don't think you can really tell until
they get very very close to it and even
when they get there so when Theresa May
took over there was a sort of sense in
the political world well she's been
pretty good as Home Secretary and she
probably is what's being apparently she
hasn't really been able to make the step
up so you don't you don't know macron
again he didn't know I met my chronomaly
is incredibly he's a very very special
politician describe I think he's got
something very very special and I think
he will be great for France and we do at
the moment seem to have a very very weak
crop of political politicians and and
that is a danger for the country it
really is that's why I mean it's
ridiculous that Jacob Riis MOG has
become this sort of huge figure in our
politics is it really of you well
honestly it's like the the the the image
we are projecting to the world at the
moment we becoming a joke I ask you
about mental health campaigning and your
involvement with that and I know that
your brother wasn't well he had
schizophrenia didn't he is that how you
first got involved campaigning yeah when
I first got involved campaigning on
mental health when I started work for
Tony and the press started to write
about the fact that I had a breakdown
you know because it was weird to go from
a position where these journalists who
used to be well still are but my mates
suddenly writing about me doing profiles
and of course they know everything about
me so they started to write about it and
I could have said hold on a minute this
is the past and you have to do this but
I just decided to be very very open
about it I've never ever regretted that
and then the charities as it were came
to me mind and rethink and these other
charities that I've worked with but yeah
the real reason was not my my mother
never wanted me to talk about Donald
when he was alive after after my mother
died he actually did because he was very
very proud of himself
he was proud that having had
schizophrenia he was diagnosed when he
was in the Army in his early 20s and he
was very very proud that he actually was
able to live quite good life now he had
20 years of his life taken away from him
by the drugs because these
antipsychotics and
powerful so when he started to get
normal illnesses it where he couldn't
find inflation so well this shitty
illness he called it didn't pair what is
a shitty omus it's just fun but it's a
horrible horrible horrible illness I
don't there's anything worse than this
sense of you mind not being your own
hearing voices I mean sometimes I would
you know you get used to living with
something like that but you see those
plugs over there don't regularly see
things coming out and the plugs and they
were coming at him and that was his that
was you know and sometimes he'd be in
situation like this and you suddenly
think why is he gone weird when he's
gone weird because he's seen this stuff
it's a horrible illness but the you know
I said when he died that he were to
Glasgow University had the same job for
almost 30 years and they were brilliant
with him because they did not see him as
a schizophrenic they saw him as an
employee who had schizophrenia and
sometimes it meant he was ill same as
sometimes you're ill with flu or you
know with you know asthma whatever it
might be so he yeah he is the real
reason I campaign on and I'm making
another film about mental illness at the
moment because I think is I think we're
making massive progress on the
understanding but we're not making
massive progress on the services what
advice would you offer could you offer
to family members who have someone
within the nearest and dearest who
suffers from a mental illness it's
really really hard that and and when we
did that when Fiona and I did a film for
the the Royals heads together campaign
and Fiona talked about how living with
me when I've had really really bad
depression back to the point where I
can't speak bad to the point where I'm
like comatose I can't not happened for a
while
mild versions of that happened on and
off all the time last time really really
really comatose like that probably a few
years ago but the thing is that what
Fiona's had to do is get used to is to
learn that it's not her fault because I
think what happens are a lot of family
members they think it's their fault I
think it's something they're doing why
then why is he like that it must be
because I'm the person that he's meant
to be closes to and so the first thing
is actually to think about yourself and
don't blame yourself but the second
thing is is just not is try not to be
judgmental the worst thing that you can
say to somebody when they're in a state
lies just do this and just do that you
just need to go and do no if only you do
this just get a job just take just go
and see a doctor just lose some weight
just go for a run just do whatever it
might be that is the worst thing you can
do you've got to be so be there and be
supportive and let them understand that
whatever the state of mind they're in
you're there for them to starting you
there for them at the end but it's very
very hard and we don't we don't think
nearly enough about the impact of mental
illness on the people and the families
and friends and how does it help when
the young royals and people are not
getting the the understand I'm not a
natural monarchist at all but the young
Royals have been absolutely brilliant
but I didn't interview with GQ with
Prince William and you know part of the
reason I did it I mean if you know
Prince William but one of the reasons I
was keen to do was really to test for
myself whether he really got this stuff
whether you really understood it whether
he was really in it you know I would
call the right reasons and I've got I've
got no doubt at all that him Harry and
and William's wife Kay reason and
they're making a massive difference
making a massive difference welcome back
when I was two Campbell was 14 his
beloved Burnley IC bragged their
transfer record for a twenty-year-old
striker named Paul Fletcher little did
the former labour spin-doctor know he
would one day end up writing a book with
him he's been telling me why I love
football and because you're a Bernie
supporter but bernie are now riding high
in the Premier League and he took two
points off these multimillionaires the
other day Etihad Stadium I think that
the I don't think I'd have written a
football novel necessarily if he hadn't
been for the fact that but coals Paul
Fletcher had the idea of writing a
football novel and then which you know
we talked about it the more we talked
about the more thought this could be a
lot of fun and you know was really
interesting I mean I love sport millions
of people love sport there are so few
good novels about sport I was I didn't
interview the other day in some
she said what's the best novel about
sport you've ever read now and if I
ended up saying and it's true this
sporting life by David's story that was
about half a century ago about rugby
league that's the best not about
football I've ever read so there aren't
so you have and I think partly you know
here we are Skye partly is because the
spectacle of the game itself is so kind
of powerful that maybe there's not as
much space for the kind of backroom
stuff and what-have-you and this
although it's about the setting is
football yeah that's the canvas yeah
well actually the backdrop is a is
Britain in 1974 we've got an election
going on you've got the IRA bombing
campaign yeah and we've got a we've got
this very struggling football manager
and these characters that he's trying to
meld as a team so no it's not I mean for
example you know if somebody who isn't
interested in football would they find
this novel interesting I think they
would because the characters are really
interesting the story is really
interesting that in the end is what you
know hopefully a good novel is about is
it writing a novel to writing your
Diaries
well the diaries are totally different
because the Diaries a different skill
yeah totally because the Diaries are
just III almost seem a diary like a kind
of emotional dumping ground the end of
every day I just kind of that's it I
don't think about it very much whereas a
novel yeah and sometimes when I get
academics writing me saying you know
such and such a day really surprised you
didn't mention this was going on because
you know didn't it why would that be it
like like I can remember
not a clue it's just that that wasn't
what I was thinking about when I went to
bed that night on him six of the jurors
yep later Brown yeah what do you think
of bran back and when I was a journalist
I was probably closer to Gordon than I
was to Toni I think what's interesting
about this this latest volume from Blair
to Brown is that you can see you can
always see why it's gone wrong
in terms of the relationship really
fractured by then was it well
I do think that you know I think that no
no Gordon's people like to say it was
kind of six in one half a dozen the
other we're all at each other the whole
time I do think that there was a real
problem on Gordon's side that he could
right from the word go could maybe never
really accept that Tony was the right
leader for that time back in 1994 and
through the elections but in you know I
still have massive regard for Gordon he
is I think he's a is a huge figure I
mean you look at you look at our
politicians today and you just think you
know Tony and Gordon different league to
what we've got in government now in
terms of their ability to get stuff done
and their clarity about what they were
trying to do you mean do you mean the
prime minister or do you mean the leader
of the Labour Party well I think
political leadership generally I'm
afraid I think we've got a real problem
with political leadership in this
country at the moment I don't know why
it is I don't know I think I think a lot
of it is to do possibly with the fact
that there's so much I think a lot of it
is I'm afraid about the way music covers
politics I think he's I think it's a
fact though fewer and fewer people are
even thinking about political career so
therefore the pool is getting narrower
and narrower and narrower and you see
this sort of people I mean honestly I
look at people in the in the cabinet
today some of them mean I think there
are some people there you can see it you
know come reasonably competent of you
but very few of them would have gone
into a cabinet 20 years ago she talking
about brexit and and Donald Trump being
elected we all seem to have sort of
tipped off our axis a bit but none of
the things that we were expecting to
happen have happened you litical ii
certainly what do you think about room
please my flesh crawl absolutely waste
by first crawl America is no china's
coming up in the rails but America is
the most powerful country in the world
and I think we've always looked up to
America a little bit in terms of its
world leadership and the fact that he's
turning his back on the world America
first climate change not a problem
this constant running down of other
countries whether it's the Shi T holes
or it's the NHS is broke or
having a go at Sadiq Khan it's just
bizarre weird but I think what is what I
find most worrying is that America
elected somebody who forget what he is
now who we knew had all these
characteristics who we knew was abusive
who we knew was have this horrible kind
of authoritarian racist side who we knew
as a misogynist who we knew had this
very loose relationship with the truth
we knew all that and yet they related
him and could elect him again I think
it's entirely possible he could be there
for for eight years if the Democrats
don't get their act together but I think
it's really really bad and dangerous for
the world and that actually is the other
reason why I think Europe Europe is the
place where I think the world can get
proper leadership at the moment are you
write a book about it about Trump no
I've read the other one I've read the
fire and fury book and even if it what
even if it is true it's a nightmare and
I look at macron I look at Merkel sort
of I know she's kind of you know
struggling a bit at the moment but the
tragedy for breaks it for me is that
we're pulling out of what I think could
be the place where you get real
leadership in the world in the next
generation how important a strong women
to you my daughter for example who is 23
and she's she's very very very
passionate feminist and she's actually
making something for TV at the moment
about about feminism and I love it I
love the fact that she's she's got this
strength and obviously a lot of it comes
from comes from Fiona and I hope a bit
for me actually cuz I'd I do think that
you know your profession at the moment
this battle of our equal pay at the BBC
and what-have-you my grace my daughter
obviously that women still don't have
equal pay it's against the law it is
absurd in 2018 that a woman doing the
same job as a bloke is somehow thought
to be worth less it is absurd but
culture takes an awful long time to
change so yeah a strong women very
important of and I know for a fact if I
hadn't stuck by me when I was having
real difficulties in my life I had to be
God knows where I'd be we saw the House
of Lords the other day and we saw
or our friend Tessa Jowell stand up and
make her speech very statesman like
wasn't she'd it's not just about money
but also the power of kindness
Walter listen Tessa's really really
close friend of ours we were away with
their Christmas in New Year and she's
been amazing and she is an amazing
person actually this is why really
angers me when people go politicians
that all the same they're all in for
themselves and what have you
Tessa is the best of public service in
politics she totally totally driven by
doing whatever even now even now with
the brain tumor she's campaigning to get
better treatment for people with brain
tumors and she that speech you made in
the House of Lords was absolutely
incredible
given that as I know having spent time
with her over the holiday just before
just how ill she's been and also the
effect that is having on you know she
speaks and like you know a commander of
language and so forth to stand up as she
didn't make that speech was incredible
but she's an incredible person she
really is
[Applause]
Alastair Campbell speaking about his
friend Tessa Jowell also talking to us
about his new book Saturday bloody
Saturday